FOR ABCEWS, AW ABOUT MOREEWS,
>>> DRN IN
RICAL  MNIVE BOOPS
RUSSIA SINCE ID UKRAINE EB
PUTIA PARTL
ONATELY.
BRITAIN'S DEFENSE ETS
TROOPSG  INVASION ISTHEY'VS WIT
RUSSIAN-OC
WAS RFALSE CLAIMS AND C
OMINOUCLGE WITH
PUTIOMG TO DEFEND HIS
Y.
>> Translator: THIS IS NOT ZE C
SURE THAT THE TEOR
INTEGRITY  HND FREEDOM WILL BE
ENSURED.
US WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONSHOULD
KNOW THAT THE PREVAILING WINDS
CAN TURN IN THEIR DIRECTION.
>> TS COMECKTH
THE WAR ON UKR DNVERSATIONS.
T K
LENSKYY  HOURS FRONO
RESS WRSRETE
ALL OF THIS ASNE OINING RUSSIA
THIS WEEK.
ITAL
DING THA AS FEF DEFEAT
E COVERING ALL THE ELEMENTS.LETA
N .
0  T MN  WHADOS HIS SPEECH
LOL RUSSIA.
SO IT S THE FIRST THING TH
RU WOKE UP THI
GOMEE ASSURANCES HEARD Y MOBILIY
HADE KIND O
VALUE TO THE ONGT THEY CIALIT
IN UKRAI
DEERF THE TRY LATER  WOULD
BE,000
WOULD BE ADDED TE NUMBER OTS TH.
SO THAT'S A MASSIVE SORT O
N POWER
THAT RUSSIA LL BE LEBRING TO TH.
O COMES NOT JUST E BACKDROPF NEA
BADR ANNOUNCEMENT BYAI
THOSGI UKRAINE
THAT THERE WOUUM
JOIN THE RUSSI THE
EXPECTATION IS THEY AL
VOTE TO JOIN WITH RUSSIAD  PIN
THAT ONCE THESTE TERRITORIES PAR
OF RUSSIA, A ATTACK AGAINS
WOD
THREGA THE HOMELAN AN
CKITSELF ANDMINDED RUSSIANS,
Y,THAT RUSSIA NUR
CAPABILITIES AND AS YOU JUST
HEARD, HE SAID IT IS NOT A BLUFF
AND HE WOULD USE THEM TO D
COESSARY.
ESFORE, BUT CLEARL
RE TO HAVE
TO BE A LO RLATIONIANS AND WEST
TO NUCLEARONEWANK YORA S IPEAG
>> Reporter: WE'RE WATCHING OSEH
PUTIN AND NS SINGOAT
300,SEDOAT THE,  TROOPS THERE?
ONE OFHE PROBLEMS FOR THINCE BE.
THE COMMAND AND L, THE
COMMUNICNS ABL
COMBANS.
SO CONENY  FROM.E N
UNENSIVE HAS BEEN AB LOORT . LOL
GEINE AN AEYN.
UE
ICH IS SOMETHINGHE U
OBVIOUSLY HAS SEEN BORON HAS TH
GET INTO AHEE T
TH
PUTIN NOT TCALLY
IT.
TH SAID, THEA
CAPABI T
N AN
CLY SAY
I K 'SY FAIR TSAY THAT I
TOT PRESIDENT  WN  ADDRESSES TH
U.N. GERAL
>>
NTION WILL B
PAID TO THOSE SP TODAY
AN
300,000 NEW , ALBEIT LAYTON.
RESERVISTSOP ALREADY
INSIDE RUSSIA. WHERE WOULDMAKE
G.
IT DN THE KI
INTO THI SCENGO IN
UKRAINE HERE.
WHHEY MIGHT T BE ED TO CUHESE P
IS WHER
UKE HAS D HAVE A DIFFICU
TI AREA BU THE
RUSSIANS CAN DE YOU GO
INHE COESSENCE, THED ROM THIS P
HERE,HOSE A THE AREAS LD MAKE
THTY,
INFANTRY TROOPS, TANK TROOPSMODS
AND KINDS OF CEY LKING A
TIN WANTS  DO
SOMETHING THROUGH BELAORARSIA.
POSSIBILITS RUSS THAT
EXTENDING THE T
ALREADY
OULD THAT DOO MORALE.
IFA LDIER
SERVININ UAI
WHO MOD YOU CAERE LONGER THABE.
D
LE AT WHOU TIN
INTO THIS AREA HHAT
THEY WOULD BING IS TRYING TO
ADVANCE THES.E TRYINGO ADVANCFO
HT FOR MONTHS NOW, FOR SEVENOR G
DECEMBER.
SO Y'RABOUT A BUNCAT ARE GOING H
RANING
AND ALSO HERE IN T A THERE.
TO DO ANYTNG TO BE TOUGH O DO AR
DITHE RUSSIANS T
GET T
RESERVIS,ONS ABOUT THEIINLYAT'
WHICH THEY WOULD NEED A LOT .
'RGOING TO
HAVE AE
S D INS QUICKLY TH
>>EAR FR
THEY SEE THI SIGN OF
WEAKNESS OF RUSSIA.THERE IS ALS
AT.
SAYIN YOUTHREAT WHERE
RUIAEGTY.UFFINGHOW SEDO IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE RER
IN THE AREAS YOU HE WHICH LLELY
ALBE AVOTE JOIN
RUSSIA WITE NEXT
AREAS, THERE ARE FOUR OF THEM TO
INCLUDE THNB REGION, ATHAT THEV
CAPTURED AS PARTD
IDESE ARE THE AREAS  KHERSO THE
AREA TY'
THE REFERENDUM.
HEO PRIA
TEITE'G TETHIS PARIN
TH THE RUSSI
NG THAT,IS
NATO'S REACTION TO THIS IS